dans l'épisode 9 on a parlé de
régression linéaire la régression
linéaire c'est chercher à expliquer une
variable y allait de des variables x1 x2
jusqu'à xd autrement dit ça revient à
déterminer comment ces variables se
combinent pour causer y est idéalement
on devrait ainsi pouvoir écrire quelque
chose comme y est égal à bêta 1 x on
puisse bêta 2 x 2 et ainsi de suite
jusqu'à état dxt intuitivement site bêta
1 est strictement positif et très grand
ça veut dire que x 1 a une grande
influence positive sur y est à l'envers
ce 6 beta 2 nuls
ça veut dire qu'il n'a aucune influence
sur y ainsi déterminer les créations y
est égale à la bêta 1 x 1 + péta ii x2
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à bêta de xtc
déterminer les causes de y
alors je parle ici de cause pour faire
simple mais en fait la notion de
causalité est très compliqué et subtile
notamment à cause du paradoxe de simpson
mais faisons simple pour aujourd'hui ce
qu'on aurait pu faire pour déterminer
les coefficients bêta 1 bêta 2 jusqu'à
bêta d c'est partir d'une théorie plus
fondamentales et utiliser quelque chose
comme le développement limité donc on a
parlé dans un épisode sur la relativité
mais pour déterminer des coefficient
bêta 1 bêta 2 jusqu'à bêta dès adéquat
la régression linéaire elle nous invite
à nous appuyer sur un jeu de données
d'entraînement chaque données
d'entraînement nous donne un ensemble de
valeurs des variables x1 jusqu'à xd et
ainsi que la valeur de y est typiquement
la cayenne données va nous donner un
vecteur de la forme xk un x cadeaux et
ainsi de suite jusqu'à xk d y cas qui
correspond donc à un point dans un
espace de dimension des plus simples où
je vais un petit peu vite sur tout ça
parce qu'on en a déjà parlé dans un
épisode précédent
maintenant on apparaît dans l'épisode 15
du théorème fondamental de
l'apprentissage statistiques qui disait
en gros que pour éviter la
surinterprétation il fallait 100 fois
plus de données que d'explication
potentiel dans notre cas ça veut dire
qu'en gros pour avoir une régression
linéaire qui se généralisera bien aux
données non encore observé il faut avoir
en gros des plus petits que n / 100 mais
le problème c'est qu'il arrive en fait
souvent que des est très grand
typiquement si chaque donnée est un
génome humain et si l'on cherchait à
prédire l'addiction au chocolat à partir
du génome alors le nombre de causes
potentielles et chaque lettre du génome
ce qui nous fait des milliards de cos
potentiel est là on est embêté parce
qu'il n'ya que 7 milliards
humains sur terre donc même en
séquençant le génome de tous les humains
vous ne pourrez pas avoir des plus
petits que n / 100 et on sera donc
nécessairement en grave danger de
surinterprétation de même si on cherche
à faire de l'analyse d'image automatisés
comme par exemple reconnaître le chat de
tristan sur une photo on risquera alors
de devoir traiter des images avec des
millions de pixels
sauf que je doute qu'il y ait des
millions d'image du charles de tristan
bref en pratique on a même des cas où
des et plus grand qu elle c'est à dire
des cas où il y a plus de causes
potentielles que de données on parle de
cas larges plis small and oui parce
qu'en statistique qu'il utilise
traditionnellement plutôt la lettre p
que la lettre d alors historiquement
pour traiter de tels cas on faisait du
bidouillage de données brutes à la main
typiquement l'analyse d'image et l
analyse d'un petit nombre de
caractéristiques des images et on
faisait ensuite la régression linéaire
sur ses caractéristiques pas sur les
données brutes
ceci étant dit peut-on néanmoins trouver
une façon entièrement automatisée
d'apprendre à partir de and honey
seulement où chacune des des causes
potentielles est vraiment prise en
compte tout en évitant le danger de la
surinterprétation même lorsque n est
plus grand voire bien plus grand que des
et bien l'astuce c'est de ne pas
s'autoriser toutes les explications
possibles par des causes ou plus
précisément on va mettre dans le chapeau
à explications uniquement des vecteurs
explicative des terrains et bêta d pour
lesquels il n'y a qu'une poignée de
coefficient bêta ils n'ont nulle
autrement dit on va autoriser
l'invocation des des causes mais on ne
va s'autoriser que les combinaisons de
ces causes parmi ces des causes c'est à
dire des vecteurs dont les coefficients
bétail seront nulles
à l'exception de ces d'entre eux est la
raison pour laquelle ces explications
qui ne combinent uniquement que ces
causes est vite bel et bien la
surinterprétation c'est qu'il y en a
beaucoup moins que d'explication à des
causes
on dit parfois que le vecteur bêta doit
être creux ou sparse en anglais ou
encore qui doit avoir une norme zéro
inférieur à ses hommes ça c'est un petit
peu la philosophie derrière l'idée de
régularisation mais le problème qui se
pose en pratique c'est que cette norme
zéro n'est pas pratique pour les calculs
d'optimisation certes elle est facile à
calculer
mais d'une certaine manière le chapeau
des explications à norme zéro inférieur
à c est un chapeau difformes
une main numérisés aura du mal à
explorer adéquatement formellement tout
ceci à voir avec la notion de convexité
des espaces on en reparlera plus tard
dans cette série bref pour des raisons
d'efficacité algorithmique il est en
fait utile de remplacer la norme zéro
par une approximation facile à calculer
typiquement la norme 1 où la norme 2
surtout la normale j'aime bien la norme
heures alors dans un corps de machine
learning il faudrait que je m'arrête sur
ces notions
mais tout ce que vous avez besoin de
retenir pour aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
s'agit d'approximations de la norme zéro
et que cette norme zéro compte le nombre
de causes impliqué par le vecteur
d'explication bêta reste maintenant la
question du choix de la valeur de ces
intuitivement c'est une mesure d'
complexité du chapeau d'explication en
fait on est vraiment dans le cadre de
l'épisode 13 ou une trop grande valeur
de ces nous pousse à la
surinterprétation d'où la question
comment choisir c'est bien la solution
classique et la régularisation
l'idée de la régularisation c'est qu'au
lieu de s'interdire la complexité on va
se contenter de pénaliser la complexité
autrement dit quels que soient leur
complexité
toutes les explications demeureront
plausible mais comme le dirait carte
sagan toute explication extraordinaire
c'est à dire une explication avec une
grande valeur de ces requiert des
preuves extraordinaires
intuitivement ça consiste à prendre
notre chapeau et à mettre les
explications trop complexe au fond du
chapeau et à privilégier les
explications en eau du chapeau autrement
dit l'astuce majeur de la régularisation
c'est de prendre des chapeaux donc
toutes les explications ne sont pas
initialement au même niveau
certaines explications seront alors plus
crédible a priori et à niveau
explicatifs et gale seront donc
privilégiés
cette astuce a vraiment révolutionné le
machine learning puisque d'une certaine
manière il permet d'ajuster le niveau
d'interprétation en fonction non
seulement de la quantité de données dont
on dispose
mais aussi et surtout en fonction de la
complexité même des données
intuitivement si aucune explication
simple n'explique bien les données et
s'il y a une explication un peu plus
compliqué mais qui colle parfaitement
aux données il sera alors justifiable
d'invoquer cette explication un peu plus
compliqué et ça soit dit en passant
c'est doublement bézian comme principe
et oui on en parlera
et pas aujourd'hui donc intuitivement
d'une certaine manière la régularisation
permet d'automatiser efficacement la
validation croisés mais il ya une autre
explication de l'efficacité de la
régularisation dans l'épisode 12 on a vu
que la variance de l'apprentissage est
un jeu de donner à l'autre était
vraiment la cause de la
surinterprétation bien justement
intuitivement en favorisant les
explications qui ne s'écartent pas trop
de l'explication de base consiste à dire
que rien ne causent y on évite trop de
variance dans l'apprentissage est donc
dans les prédictions de cet
apprentissage l'apprentissage et
intuitivement robuste à des variations
des données d'entraînement et ce qui est
amusant c'est qu'on a découvert que la
régularisation est mathématiquement
équivalente à d'autres approches qui s'
attaquer directement à cette robustesse
par exemple une solution pour garantir
cette robustesse consiste à apprendre
non seulement des données collectées
mais aussi de données fictives obtenu en
perturbant légèrement les données
collectées
intuitivement un bon apprentissage ne
devrait pas être bouleversé par ces
petites perturbations
cette approche est appelée
l'augmentation des données de manière
plus formelle c'est aussi équivalent à
supposer que les données collectées sont
des données imprécises qui ne sont donc
que des approximations des vraies
données c'est-à-dire des données qui
auraient été obtenues si les
expérimentateurs n'avait pas commis
d'erreur de mesures du coup plutôt que
d'apprendre des données collectées
l'optimisation dite robuste consiste à
considérer que les vraies données sont
quelque part à côté des données
collectées et qu'il faut que nos
explications soient valides
quelle que soit la position exacte des
vrais donné formellement
ça revient à introduire un ensemble dit
d'incertitude autour de la données
collectées et à chercher des
explications qui colle le mieux au pire
cas autrement dit on va chercher le
modèle qui maximise l'explication de la
pire valeurs de la vraie donnée possible
sachant que cette donnée est dans
l'ensemble d'incertitude et bien la
théorie de la dualité en optimisation un
coup de la grange un et deux points
salle permet de montrer que
l'optimisation robuste est en fait
équivalente à la régularisation
autrement dit non seulement la
régularisation permet d'automatiser la
validation croisés et d'explorer ainsi
des explications complexes dans les
situations où les explications simples
sont insuffisantes
mais elle permet aussi de lutter contre
la variance de l'apprentissage et
d'anticiper le fait que les données
d'entraînement sont des données
collectées et qu'elles ont donc de
bonnes chances de ne pas être exactement
des mesures du phénomène étudié tout ça
fait qu'aujourd'hui avec la sagesse des
forêts la régularisation est devenu la
solution privilégiée des praticiens du
machine learning pour lutter contre la
surinterprétation les infos dans les
commentaires ici est revenu sur le
paradoxe simpson il est proposé un autre
problème ou fait trouver un facteur de
confusion à savoir le problème où on
avait des fumeurs qui avaient un taux de
survie plus grand que des non fumeurs
sur une période de 20 ans et je vous
avais demandé de trouver des facteurs de
confusion de ce phénomène et vous avez
été très très imaginatif et récréatif
dans les commentaires à trouver pendant
de bonnes idées pour pouvoir expliquer
ce phénomène par exemple s'il elle
propose au fait qu'il y a peut-être des
différences de classe économique entre
les fumeurs et non fumeurs peut-être que
du coup les fumeurs temps d'une classe
socio économique plus élevée du coup ils
ont plus accès à toutes sortes de biens
de santé
samedi gobbi imagine que les gens qui
fument font du coup plus attention à
leur santé puisqu'ils sont ça qui sont
en plus grand risque
ils ont plus grand facteur de risque et
du coup en faisant attention à leur
santé en fait ils améliorent davantage
leur santé que les gens qui ne fume pas
elle qui du coup ne ferait pas attention
à leur santé
et d'ailleurs ça c'est une explication
de risque alpha dans sa vidéo sur
l'obésité pour expliquer pourquoi est ce
que les gens qui sont en surpoids en
fait un meilleur taux de survie que des
gens qui sont dans le poids idéal
ceci rejoint d'ailleurs la remarque
d'hannibal à steam qui suggère le fait
que les fumeurs sont davantage suivis
médicalement
enfin que je sois sinico james buchanan
arturo grégory grands genres et à celle
0,37 on mentionnait le facteur aux
fonctions qui est l'âge et c'est celui
qui apparaît en tout cas dans la vidéo
de tes dettes dont vous nous invite à
aller voir
en fait je vous invite à ne pas aller
voir ça je lui posais un autre prenne
deux facteurs poussant puisque vous avez
l'air d'aimer ça donc il ya des études
aux états unis qui montrent par exemple
que les noirs et les blancs ont le même
taux de 100 ans à mort lors des procès
du coup ça laisse suggérer qu'en fait il
n'y a pas de discrimination devant la
loi entre les blancs et les noirs
mais est ce vraiment le cas ce qu'il n'y
aura pas un facteur de contenu
ce qui fait qu'on a ce résultat malgré
l'existence d'une discrimination entre
les blancs et les noirs et vous voyez
que tout de suite quand ça parle de
trucs un peu plus tôt j là tout de suite
ça c'est un peu plus difficile de
prendre un grand coup de respiration et
décide de chercher ces facteurs de
confusion qui est vraiment la difficulté
du paradoxe de simpson puisque je vois
beaucoup de gens dire que le cas du
paradoxe de simpson était évident dans
le cas du match de football entre tenté
et radio mais en fait quand on parle de
politique sous leur truc arrive tout le
temps il faut vraiment avoir le réflexe
de se dire il y à des facteurs de
confusion qui sont toujours classe ou
toujours caché je dirais même que même
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de facteur de
confusion évident on pourra jamais
exclure le fait qu'il n'y en a pas et du
coup ne pourra jamais faire pleinement
confiance à des statistiques globales il
a ça me permets d'insister sur l'intérêt
notamment des expériences scientifiques
contrôler puisque l'intérêt de ces
expériences est justement de contrôler
ces facteurs de confusion et de savoir
vraiment quel est l'effet qui est
vraiment testé il vous renvoie vers
vidéo de cette esthétique explique rocha
notamment pour mieux comprendre tout ça
yoann des à racheter et sous coup d
envoi la vidéo de leur typologie sur la
sagesse de youtube où il parle notamment
du fait que la diversité permettrait de
faire de meilleures prédictions
alors j'ai des petits bémols à mettre à
cette vidéo de léo qui ont
volontairement un théorème appelé le
théorème de la diversité des prédictions
et alors à ma connaissance ce théorème a
été purement nommé ainsi étudié ainsi
par le chercheur scott pays du et voilà
je suis un petit peu dur avec scott
match mais je pense que cette
interprétation du en fait eu c'est
l'interprétation d'une autre équation
qui est le 10ème violences dont apparu
dans l'épisode 12
je pense que cette interprétation est
complètement fallacieuse tout simplement
parce que lorsqu'on regarde l'équation
qui est présenté par deux typologies
lorsqu'on augmente la diversité dans une
population
eh bien on augmente aussi l'erreur
individuelle moyenne de la même quantité
même mathématiquement sûr nous manque le
même bruit dans la diversité des
prédictions façon complètement mécanique
et bien il va avoir le même bruit qui a
rajouté à l'erreur individuelle moyenne
si bien que l'erreur collectif reste
complètement inchangé et ça c'est
vraiment l'équation biais variance quand
on a déjà parlé dans l'épisode 12 avec
gilles de la chaîne oreca donc je sais
pas du tout pour critiquer les eaux
puisque bien fait son travail lui dire
il a cité ses sources et
la vidéo est très bien mais
l'explication qu'il donne et sens pas du
tout la bonne et ça vient d'une
interprétation fallacieuse de scott pays
que de cette équation particulier pour
répondre à la question de pierre stoeber
non la sagesse des forêts est à mon sens
pas du tout un argument en faveur de la
démocratie en fait de façon plus
rigoureuse qui marche au vraiment bien
dans cette sagesse des forêts c'est si
on applique quelque chose comme ada
boost ou l'algorithme par multiplient
typhoïde se blesse c'est à dire si non
seulement on prend en compte une
certaine diversité mais on fait quand
même gaffe à donner plus d'importance à
des arbres qui non seulement explique
bien les données mais en plus de cela
sont relativement simples
en gros la diversité est importante mais
il faut quand même une sélection des
arbres les plus performants ou plus
généralement des avis les plus informés
si on s'intéresse à des questions
scientifiques
bref la diversité aides mais ce n'est
pas une condition suffisante il faut
aussi quelque part avoir ce travail sur
les pondérations en fait des différents
arbres de la forêt est en fait vous pour
à montferrand fait en pratique un vote
pondéré et donner plus d'importance non
pas des arbres aléatoire mais plutôt à
des arbres qui déjà sont pas si mal pour
expliquer les données observées
nassim aux burgers nous demande si les
arbres ne devrait pas appliquer le
scrutin de condorcet randomisés
lorsqu'ils vont aller aux urnes
- la réponse en fait est généralement il
n'y a pas trop besoin parce que le fait
le scrutin de converser en dominer qu'il
a vraiment cette bonne propriété d'être
robuste au dilemme du vote utile si on
suppose que les arabes vote de façon
honnête en particulier vu qu'on contrôle
la manière dont ils vont voter qui
correspond en gros à leur score mais
alors capacité à expliquer les données
observées
vu qu'on contrôle ça et qu'on connaît
toutes les données n'a pas besoin
d'avoir cette robustesse diem du vote
utile et à ce moment là je pense qu'une
votation par score par par note
c'est quelque chose qui marche on fait
beaucoup beaucoup mieux est en fait la
version vraiment ultime de tout ça c'est
je pense en tout cas une approche
purement bayésienne ou la prédiction de
la forêt et une moyenne pondérée qui est
donnée par la loi des probabilités total
encore une fois il y aura beaucoup plus
à dire sur ce sujet j'ai ça pour une
autre fois au solo sur pose la question
de l'interprétation lité de ces fois
puisqu'en fait une des grosses
difficultés de ces arbres vu qu'ils nous
donnent pas d'explications chaque arbre
nous donne des explications à fait
incompatible avec les autres arbres
c'est un peu bizarre du 6 et 5 ans des
explications avec du coup c'est
également très difficile à interpréter
tout ça la réponse à tout ça ça serait
surtout que peut-être que ce qu'on
appelle explications de façon visuelle
c'est pas forcément une bonne façon de
penser l'épistémologie de savoir qu est
ce qu on sait qu est ce qu on sait pas
finalement ce qu'on serait pas en train
de chercher finalement des modèles
prédictifs à chaque fois pour essayer de
prédire à chaque fois un maximum des
choses qui nous arrive est finalement
tout ça posera en fait la question de
cas ce que signifie vraiment qui
expliquait quelque chose de comprendre
quelque chose
est-ce qu'à voir les explications de
quelque chose ça a un sens où est-ce
qu'on ne serait pas tout simplement de
petites machines très limités dont la
complexité de somme 9 est très inférieur
à la complexité sur le neuf de l'univers
et du coup on ne peut de toute façon que
se contenter des algorithmes de
compression qui sont à la fois
incroyablement rapide et est
incroyablement simple à décrire et que
du coup bah on n'est pas capable de
décrire non seulement le fonctionnement
de tout bois mais également le
fonctionnement de tout notre univers je
pencherais plutôt vers cette option
et du coup ça veut dire que la seule
chose qui soit vraiment d'intérêt
vis-à-vis de notre description du monde
et en avoir des descriptions
approximatif utile acheter avec tous les
modèles sauf ao certains sont utiles ce
hashtag il sous-entend aussi qu'il n'ya
pas grand chose au delà des modèles voir
si ce n'est peut-être les données qui
nous sont fournis pour ajuster nos
modèles enfin rémy perd nos demandes ne
signera pas une façon de concilier ses
idées de sagesse des forêts avec des
théories plus classique de
l'apprentissage notamment cette histoire
de dimension baisser si vous
réfléchissez en fait c'est une façon de
réduire toute la complexité d'un chapeau
à un seul nombre et c'est peut-être un
petit peu trop simplificateur et que
peut-être que pour bien parler des
chapeaux explications il faut avoir une
option beaucoup plus sophistiqué que
juste sa dimension en v c est
typiquement dans le cas d'une forêt qui
a beaucoup plus que la simple complexité
baissé de la foi et qui importe il ya la
manière dont notamment elle évolue et
s'adapte aux données au fur et à mesure
notamment cette idée que à chaque fois
qu'on me donne une nouvelle donnée à la
forêt à la forêt va s'ajuster un petit
peu à cette donnée
mais forêt va a priori pas trop bouger
parce que c'est tout une grosse
structure intuitivement et en tout cas
pas complètement être bouleversée et
sèchement cependant ça qui fait la
sagesse de la forêt c'est le fait que
toutes données individuelles ajoutés ou
modifiés ne va pas bouleverser
complètement la forêt ça ça revient à
aussi étudier non seulement le
l'ensemble des hypothèses considérées
mais aussi le mécanisme d'apprentissage
c'est quelque chose qui je pensais pas
forcément souvent étudiée par les
théories classiques de l'apprentissage
il ya d'autres théories par contre
qu'ils étudient soir de choses notamment
il a tout le champ de l'apprentissage en
temps réel ou online learning en anglais
je vous renvoie notamment vers les
vidéos que j'ai fait sur un dida sur le
multi végétal gaudin qui est typiquement
une façon de mesurer la capacité
d'apprentissage en fait d'une initiative
ait des algorithmes army des white
stripes et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que dans cette analyse en fait on est
une analyse cumulative dynamique de la
manière dans l'apprentissage se fait et
je pense que c'est peut-être plus
pertinent que les approches un peu
classique le saint graal vraiment de
tout ça étant je pense notamment le
théorème de complétude de se lever 9
pour la formule du ps mais ça on en
parlera mais pas aujourd'hui
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
qui clôt une mini-série dans cette maxi
série qui est parlée dover fitting magna
sur interpellation qui est vraiment un
point fondamental
je pense qu'on ne peut pas comprendre
l'intérêt par exemple de la sagesse des
forêts sans prendre en compte ces idées
de surinterprétation puisque voilà ci
avait pas de preuves de
surinterprétation lloret pas d'intérêt
je pense avoir une forêt d'explications
ou à voir ses idées de régularisation à
partir de la prochaine vidéo pour
quelques vidéos on va parler du problème
de dimensionner alité on prend parfois
du fléau de la dimensionné ou encore de
la malédiction de la dimensionnalité qui
est le fait que en fait en machine
learning ou s'intéressent souvent à des
données qui sont de très très très
grande dimension et que les espaces de
très très très connus sont aussi des
espaces très très bizarre il faut
absolument des simplifier une certaine
rien en particulier la prochaine fois on
va parler des hyperboles et des hyper se
faire c'est ball maxi boulot de très
grande dimension
qu'ils ont fait en fait incroyablement
packing étrange et pas mal des couleurs
notamment très récemment en
m'intéressant à ce sujet et ça beaucoup
d'applications en machine donne
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
le lac est le commentaire de partage et
pensez à vous abonner pour une lecture
épisode martiaux teaser pour leurs dons
et j'espère que je serai là
la prochaine fois